on a tous l'habitude de voir ou de
toucher du sable c'est une matière qui
nous est familière d'ailleurs on
retrouve du sable pas seulement sur les
plages mais sur une bonne partie de la
surface de la planète et pourtant c'est
une substance un peu étrange quand on le
regarde de près pas de doute un le sable
c'est un solide des petits grains de la
civis la plupart du temps qui sont comme
de minuscules cailloux mais si on en
prend une poignée et bien le sable c'est
cool on peut même le ver c'est presque
comme si c'était un liquide
alors évidemment le sable ça n'est pas
un liquide on voit bien d'ailleurs on
peut marcher sur le sable alors que a
priori on peut pas marcher sur l'eau
autre différence avec un liquide quand
on fait s'écouler du sable et bien une
forme un tas le sable est ce qu'on
appelle un milieu granulaire constitué
de grains et qui se comporte à mi chemin
entre un liquide et un solide il a des
propriétés bien particulière qu'on
comprend pas encore complètement et
c'est pas seulement pour le plaisir de
faire des châteaux de sable qu'on étudie
on retrouve en effet des milieux
granulaires dans tout un tas
d'applications qu'ils s'agissent
d'agriculture de l'industrie
agroalimentaire des matériaux de
construction ou encore en géophysique
pour mieux comprendre des phénomènes
comme des avalanches ou des éboulements
commençons par cette constatation qui
distingue le sable d'un liquide canton
le verse
ils forment un tas généralement ce tas
est un cône avec un certaine angle à la
base et ce qui est étonnant c'est que
pour un sable données quelle que soit la
quantité l'angle semble toujours le même
et si on essaie d'imposer un angle plus
élevé le tas revient à son angle initial
mais qu'est ce qui détermine la valeur
de cet angle pour l'étudier de manière
précise
on peut faire un petit montage avec un
cylindre tournant l'idée est de remplir
le cylindre à moitié ou un peu moins et
de le faire tourner lentement à
l'horizontale pour observer l'angle à
partir duquel le sable c'est cool
si on fait pas ça à la plage mais en
laboratoire avec un montage approprié on
constate qu'il ya en réalité deux angles
celui à partir duquel l'avalanche se
déclenche
ap les angles d'avalanche est celui
auquel elle se stabilise ap les angles
de repos ses angles vont varier avec la
nature du sable et dépendent
principalement de la forme des grains et
de leurs rugosité en surface mais aussi
comme vous pouvez vous en douter de lui
inité du sable bah oui l'humidité joue
clairement un rôle puisque si vous
prenez du sable mouillé
tout le monde sait qu'on peut faire un
château c'est à dire en quelque sorte un
tas dont l'angle à la base des 90 degrés
ou presque
pour comprendre ce qui se passe avec un
château de sable il faut comprendre le
rôle de l'eau quand il y à peu d'eau
dans votre sable celle ci vient se
placer entre les grains et créer une
force d'attraction qu'on appelle la
force capillaire c'est en gros la même
force qui fait que le rideau de douche
en plastique quand il est mouillé va
coller sur la baignoire ou bien sur
votre peau cette force capillaire assure
la cohésion des grains de sable pour
qu'une structure en châteaux de sable
fonctionne bien il faut qu'il y ait
suffisamment d'eau pour créer tous ces
petits ponts capillaire entre les grains
mais pas trop parce que s'il commence à
y avoir des poches d'eau la structure
s'affaiblit et peut s'effondrer
donc il y à un niveau d'humidité
optimale dans une publication de 2012
des physiciens se sont amusés à chercher
cet optimum et ils ont trouvé environ 1
% d'eau en volume par rapport aux sables
pour des grains d'environ 100 microns en
plus de ça ils ont montré que quand on
se place à l'optimum on peut construire
des structures aussi hautes que celles
qu'on pourrait faire avec un matériau
solide normale et que la hauteur
maximale avant que la tour ne deviennent
instables dépend du diamètre de la base
selon une formule classique avec ça ils
ont construit par exemple des structures
d'un mètre de haut avec une base de
seulement 7 cm de diamètre une des
propriétés étonnantes du sable c'est que
quand il est suffisamment bien tassés si
on essaye de le déformer cela le conduit
à se dépasser c'est à dire qui se dilate
canton le déforme et c'est assez
contre-intuitif généralement quand vous
exercer une pression sur un solides
poreux par exemple du pain il va plutôt
se contracter et pas se dilater cette
propriété étonnante du sable est appelée
l'adie latence et y en existe une
illustration bien connu quand vous
marchez sur du sable mouillé juste à la
marée descendante
vous pouvez constater que le sable
devient blanc sous vos pas et bien c'est
à cause de ça le sable est initialement
bien tassée et quand vous le déformer
sous vos pieds il ne peut que se dilater
comme il augmente de volume le qu'il
contient doit se répartir sur ce volume
plus grand
à cet endroit le sable devient donc
moins humide et s'éclaircit légèrement
avant que l'eau alentour ne viennent
remplir les interstices à nouveau mais
voici une autre expérience assez
spectaculaire qui joue sur cet effet dit
latence pour la faire il va vous falloir
un verre un bâton et bien sur du sable
placez le bâton verticalement dans le
vert au milieu tenait le et remplissez
de sable c'est
kippa humide tapez légèrement sur le
bord du verre pour bien tassé le sable
et recommencer deux ou trois fois
quand le verre est plein soulevé le
bâton et la surprise là le vert vient
avec
il est comme solidaires du bâton la
raison c'est que quand le sable c'est
assez les grains ont formé des arches un
peu comme dans une clé de voûte
et pour que le bâton puis sortir le
sable doit se dilater et il n'a pas la
place de le faire pour annuler l'effet
vous remuez juste un peu le bâton comme
ça ça libère la structure et le bâton
peut sortir du verre voyons maintenant
un autre type d'expérience avec un objet
qui nous est familier un sablier
vous savez peut-être qu'il existe un
objet analogue au sablier mais avec du
liquide ce qu'on appelle une clepsydre
bien que le sable soit une substance
plus complexe que l'eau pour le coup un
sablier est plus simple à utiliser qu
une clepsydre on va faire une petite
comparaison j'ai pris une bouteille
percée avec des graduations pour mesurer
le volume on va la remplir
successivement de sable et d'eau et on
va comparer le temps qu'il met pour
s'écouler
ce qu'on constate c'est que le temps que
met le sable à s'écouler ne semble pas
dépendre de la hauteur du sable pour
chaque niveau de graduation on a à peu
près la même durée au contraire l'ol
c'est cool bien plus vite au début qu'à
la fin ça sent d'ailleurs avec la
pression du jet la vitesse d'écoulement
du sable est constante et c'est
d'ailleurs bien pratique
ça veut dire que si la moitié du sable
s'est écoulé et bien la moitié du temps
est passé et ça c'est plus vrai avec un
liquide comme l'eau la première moitié
de l'eau va s'écouler plus vite que la
deuxième on peut faire une analyse
précise du phénomène avec l'eau c'est
facile on sait calculer que la vitesse
d'écoulement est égal à racine de 2 g h
i gc l'accélération de la gravité et h
la hauteur de l'eau donc l'eau
s'écoulera plus vite au début quand la
hauteur est élevée qu'à la fin dans le
cas du sable on peut montrer que la
vitesse est proportionnelle à racine de
grr est le rayon du trou pour le sable
la vitesse d'écoulement ne dépend donc
pas de la hauteur restant dans la
bouteille
elle est tout le temps là même elle
dépend juste de la taille de l'ouverture
si on observe ou qu on simule dans les
détails ce qui se passe on constate que
dans le sable secret des structures un
peu comme les arches dont on parlait
tout à l'heure et qui font que seule une
petite portion autour du trou et mise en
mouvement et que ces grains de sable en
bas ne sentent pas en quelque sorte la
pression du dessus car celle ci est
reprise par les arches qui se forment
une dernière petite expérience amusante
pour la route comme c'est l'été vous
allez peut-être prendre l'apéro et il ya
un phénomène bien connu des physiciens
de comptoir c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet noix du brésil
c'est l'idée que dans un paquet
contenant un mélange de noix et autres
cacahuètes diverses
les noix du brésil les plus grosses ont
toujours tendance à remonter à la
surface ce qui est un peu contre
intuitif en a tendance à se dire qu'en
étant plus grosses balles devrait aller
au fond on peut reproduire ce type de
phénomène de manière un peu plus
contrôlés en utilisant du sable en place
en fond un gros caillou et en tapant
[Applaudissements]
et voilà étonnamment bien que plus lourd
le gros caillou est remonté en surface
ce qui est quand même un peu bizarre
alors il ya deux explications à ce
phénomène
la première est assez intuitive quand on
secoue l'ensemble ça libère
temporairement sous le gros caillou un
petit espace dans lequel les petits
grains de sable peuvent venir se glisser
et donc peu à peu forcer le caillou à
remonter mais il ya un autre phénomène
qui rentrent en jeu et qu'on appelle la
convection granulaire c'est le fait que
quand on agite le récipient il se crée
un mouvement global des grains on voit
pas forcément toujours très bien et où
les grains proche des parois descendent
tandis que ceux vers le centre remonte
on parle de convection et ce mouvement
de rouleaux entraîne le gros caillou
jusqu'à la surface et ensuite peut même
le faire replonger près des parois alors
l'effet est amusant pour l'apéro mais
sachez que le comprendra de vraie
implication pour un certain nombre
d'applications
par exemple chaque fois qu'on doit
mélanger des milieux granulaires de
taille différents ce qui arrive dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire ou par
exemple pour les matériaux de
construction
vous voyez donc que l'étude des milieux
granulaires est un domaine passionnant
où on peut à la fois rapprocher de la
science fondamentale et des applications
pratiques tout à fait concrète
si toutes ces histoires de fluides et de
presque fluide vous amuse
je vous recommande d'aller faire un tour
sur la chaîne du projet lutétium c'est
une chaîne tenus par des étudiants en
physique et en art et qui propose plein
de belles expériences de ce genre et je
crois savoir de source sûre qu'il
prépare quelque chose sur le thème des
milieux granulaires merci d'avoir suivi
la vidéo comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à la partager la faire
connaître autour de vous mettre des
pousses bleus il part avec les pouces
bleus c'est important la cloche facebook
twitter tout ça et et puis si jamais
vous l'avez pas déjà lu sur la plage
vous pouvez aller jeter un coup d'oeil à
mon bouquin qui s'appelle un seul coup
mais vrai et puis on se retrouve très
bientôt pour des nouvelles vidéos un peu
plus lourde et dans un contexte un peu
moins estivales
à bientôt